let's pull that up and talk about how
how dark and evil this stuff gets we
have a story from fox news project
veritas's james o'keefe speaks out after
fbi raided home this is an attack on the
first amendment o'keeffe told fox news
sean hannity that he was in a state of
shock as fbi agents searched his
apartment apparently he's partially
clothed he says i wake up to a pre-dawn
raid banging on my door i went to my
door to answer the door and there were
10 fbi agents with the battering ram
white blinding lights they turned me
around handcuffed me threw me against
the hallway i was partially clothed in
front of my neighbors they confiscated
my phone they raided my apartment on my
phone where many of my reporters notes a
lot of my sources unrelated to the story
and a lot of confidential donor
information to our news organization he
says i've heard the process as the
punishment i didn't really understand
what that meant until this weekend and
sean i wouldn't wish this on any
journalist james o'keefe has a really
really great job regardless of what you
think about his politics he is a guy who
who
he posts videos of people saying things
he does undercover reporting and you
might not like it but that's all he does
for the fbi to go after him we can truly
see the depravity and the evil that is
in the establishment not just that tim i
mean
in that interview james o'keefe detailed
specifically how
they were given this diary they decided
not to run with the story and they
handed it over to the authorities
and then he got raided so so what in the
world is the fbi doing when they're
allegedly going after this diary that
was already handed over to the police
this is clear intimidation this is clear
trying to scare the crap out of
independent journalists who are actually
doing real muckraking journalism but
look what happens the fbi
white on rice on james o'keefe larry
nassler jeffrey epstein harvey weinstein
years ignoring the victims ignoring
children ignoring women that were hurt
in unspeakable ways that we can't even
mention here
was able to do whatever he wanted with
the fbi looking the other way and now
and now let's talk about james and let's
talk about how the how the establishment
media apparatus handles these stories
what how did how did we find out about
epstein it was james o'keefe publishing
leaked video of an abc news reporter
saying she had evidence and testimony on
epstein and it was scuttled away by the
media organizations and it was james
o'keefe who did the hard work to break
that story and who's getting raided by
the fbi james o'keefe who was ignored by
the by the fbi epstein the the victim
system
we're talking about thousands of
children here we're talking about the
fbi broke into his safe where they had
prominent people and politicians names
with videotapes the fbi still has this
in their in his possession epstein was
hanging out with bill gates was hanging
out with billionaires bill clinton kevin
spacey all the biggest names in politics
he was hanging out he was he had
surveillance systems inside of his homes
in almost every room and and the fbi has
in their position all of the tapes all
of the videos of very prominent people
in compromising ways why hasn't why
haven't they done anything with that can
i just say the other thing about this
whole story the the the
o'keeffe raid
um that i think is just so
like
unbelievably kind of tawdry is the way
that you know obviously the reason
they're doing it is because it's to do
with biden and his family in the diary
of the daughter and so on it's so kind
of third banana republic you know the
president kind of his family there's an
issue there's a story and it's already
been published and then they send it
they send the the cops to to harass the
girl i mean it just feels like and again
this is exactly the opposite of you know
they constantly say oh well you know
trump undermining democratic norms how
many times you heard all that stuff i
mean what is this well you sent the fbi
in because the boss's daughter's been
involved in something i mean it's just
so embarrassing
i think it's it's it's more evidence
that the establishment is crooked
that's uh our uh protects itself well
these are desperate actions by desperate
people who are trying to hit anyone
criticizing them and when we look at
project veritas they have been releasing
an onslaught of counter narrative
whistleblowing information and and
documents and videos that have exposed a
lot of the bull crap in our entire
establishment in in our entire system
this is retribution this is payback this
is them hitting the nail that stood up
because they're a hammer and once you're
a hammer the only thing you do is you
look for nails and everyone who speaks
that against them everyone who
criticizes them it's a nail that's
that's the larger messaging that we're
getting from this larger raid they want
you afraid they want to show you their
empower and that you should not speak
out against them but the opposite should
be happening here james o'keefe was told
hey
this is an ongoing investigation don't
even tell anyone this happened he went
on sean hannity uh just a couple hours
ago last night and and broke the whole
story wide open well they talked about
the details here that are extremely
important but it's an interesting theme
i mean you would see it with the written
house story with this and actually the
other one i'd add to that list is what
they did that disgusting letter
um
and you know they're calling parents
domestic terrorists you know from the
national school board association which
then you know within days um the justice
department endorsed and said yeah we're
going to put the fbi on to parents
protesting at their kids because there's
absolutely no legal justification that's
totally
you know it's unconstitutional they've
got no business of the federal
government it's not a federal law
enforcement matter why are they doing it
to intimidate the parents to stop them
from actually thinking you know they
won't know exactly what they're allowed
to do or not oh [ __ ] no we've got the
fbi i better not do that i better not
protest i don't want to get in trouble
with the law completely i mean it's
despicable actually yeah they're trying
to stop
they're trying to stop project veritas
they don't want james o'keefe doing the
work that he's doing because i will
stress probably one of the most
important points that can ever be said
we learned the epstein story broke
the arrests occurred elaine maxwell is
currently you know whatever is going on
with her she's in custody because of
james o'keefe now there are a lot of
other reporters just didn't follow that
again i'd love to just tell that explain
that well so a lot of interest he's not
the only journalist who is who was doing
this work you know mike cernovich there
was the miami um i think was the miami
herald i'm not sure but i'm just
stressing the importance of james
o'keefe getting a hold of the swedish
his organization uh i think his her name
was amy rohrbach from abc news saying
that abc shut down the story on epstein
that lit a spark
over this this story it ignited the
story everyone starts talking about it
again not just james o'keefe a lot of
the core investigative documents were
released because of the work of mike
cernovich and this other reporter
cernovich miami herald even the daily
mail surprisingly they were on it and
actually talking about this in a fair
and honest way and even the daily beast
there's a lot to even to criticize them
but they when when it comes to this
reporting they were they were doing a
lot of good stuff but but i want to
stress the importance of what james
o'keefe did in publishing that that that
evidence from a major news organization
withholding facts withholding testimony
and now the fbi who ignored epstein for
decades
is going after james o'keefe
james o'keefe what's what what what what
he's doing journalism epstein yeah we
know what he was doing and who does the
fbi target yeah they'll go to they'll go
find a garage pole rope at nascar but
they'll ignore the riots throughout the
country they'll target the journalists
this is why i i tell these back to blue
people these the law enforcement will
kick your teeth in in two seconds if
they're told to do it michael malus goes
a bit further
in his assessment of the police saying
that they'll there's no there's nothing
i don't know the exact quote he says but
there's nothing you know so agree just a
police officer wouldn't do it if
instructed up into up and including
executing children
i don't know if i'd go that far i think
most humans would be like i'm scared of
this but i think a lot of law
enforcement would absolutely we've seen
it throughout history when they're
instructed to do it they say it is
easier to just do as i'm told so that i
survive and they will do whatever
they're told
that's the story of history i mean you
look at what what happened before you
look at empires uh we also have to
understand that there's a lot of
sociopaths out there uh steve uh where
would you say the most amount of
sociopaths are located per capita
okay well i know that's pretty close to
it
yes uh very we're very close to it it's
around the washington dc area and i
think
you know we sometimes don't want to see
the world in this way or understand the
world in this way because we don't
envision ourselves going to these kind
of levels for power for money for for
for an ideology but there are people who
are sociopathic who are crazy who are
insane who do have mental disorders that
don't allow them to be as the average
human being and they think totally
differently they act totally differently
and and we can't even conceive of what
they're capable of but when you look at
history it's lessons after lessons that
the biggest thing that you should be
afraid of is giving up your rights to
the government that will ultimately
abuse them for their own personal
benefit and the benefit of their inner
circle and their and their friends their
friends are the billionaire class the
billionaire class the corporations have
been getting away robbing this country
blind within the last few months in an
extensive way that is just ah stunning
to see while the mainstream media talks
about dribble nonsense and cultural
issues when of course the real issues
that we should be talking about are the
larger ramifications of giving up
everything to the government on the
silver platter because of a tragedy
because of a bad event because of of of
something horribly happening in this
world that they are exploiting to to the
biggest experience
they have direct responsibility for that
too i mean you know i mean i've i've
i've really been pursuing this a lot on
my show which is the the direct it's
another example i think of the total
arrogance and hubris of this
technocratic elite the insular ruling
elite where you know the the fouchy role
in starting the pandemic i mean that's
the
it's another example of it we don't have
we don't have that puzzle piece
uh in terms of is covid
the virus they did gain and function
research on however
i will say this
they were doing gain of function
research in the wuhan lab
the nih was funding it in violation of
orders to not fund it but they gave
money to ecohealth alliance who then
gave money to the world lab
which was used for the production of
chimeric viruses with increased
infectivity on human cells particularly
human lung cells
we then so they're doing modified
they're modifying and making chimeric
covid viruses
then in the same town a few blocks away
from the lab where the research is
happening
this illness emerges so i'll be careful
because i will absolutely have no
problem saying we don't have the last
puzzle piece that connects those two
bridges of them doing the gain of
function research and then covet happens
and i want to be careful because
i think it's very important not to
discredit yourself by jumping the gun
i'll just say that definitive and
confirmed fauci conducted uh fauci's nih
funded gain of function research through
equal health alliance whether he knew it
or not is irrelevant it it happened
look then we get a mod then we get a
covet virus and the guy from equal
health alliance is on the the lancet
paper arguing that it's not from a lab
so the point is
i think a reasonable reasonable person
could assume
that covet leaked from a lab
and there's other look i don't want to i
could literally talk about this for
hours i've spent most of the last year
pursuing this story and we were the
first people to do on tv i think that
the just a couple of things i'd say i
really don't want to go necessarily sort
of be sidetracked onto this but a couple
of things first of all
it's
the the the people took all the time
about about actually funding this
research which implies a sort of
passivity he was there he was you know
eating the money went but maybe maybe he
didn't know no he fouchy was the leading
global world in the entire world the
leading champion of gain of function
research he wrote a piece in the
washington post 10 years ago 2011 he
wrote a piece
explicitly it says this is a verbatim
quote
engineering a dangerous virus in the
laboratory is a risk worth taking that's
fauci that's his words he's always been
the leading advocate of this ever since
this technology was invented so this is
not like him just funding it passively
he commissioned this research he
commissioned it yeah he want and and
that that's one thing
in terms of the
kind of accountability here it's
important to have that piece the second
thing i'd say i completely agree with
you we don't know for sure and i've
never said that the the phrase that i
use all the time because i think this is
the right way to put it is that it is
the most likely origin of the pandemic i
think no question and the one of the
other things to add to that is the
alternative explanation that this was a
naturally occurring virus is completely
implausible there's no evidence been
found at all for the natural um
explanation they've tested what is it 80
000 animals they haven't found an animal
host the theory that one thing we do
know is that the the
virus on which they were working because
this is specified in the um in the in
the papers that have been published is
um a virus that originated in the cave
in yunnan a thousand miles away and so
of which the workers died um a couple of
the workers died from respiratory
illnesses they didn't they didn't infect
anyone else right in their village they
didn't affect anyone else in the
healthcare system where they were
treated it wasn't airborne it was gained
a function in the lab that made it
airborne
the original virus that they're working
on the theory you have to believe if
you're going to be believe the lab
origin is that somehow this virus made
its way a thousand miles um with no
other animal host to the one place in
the entire world where they were already
working on viruses that were an exact
match for the virus we have it's so
implausible yeah so yes we don't know
for sure that that's why i i try to be
careful and say like there's completely
agree with you there's the one puzzle
piece missing where we can definitively
say here absolutely i'm very glad you
made that clear i totally agree and i've
never said for sure i've always said
most likely and i think that's the truth
but there's an extensive abundant amount
of circumstantial evidence we don't have
the smoking gun but it's there it's also
important to point out that dr fauci was
as he correctly said championing gain of
function while there was also a big
scientific community that was saying
it's pointless it's reckless and it's
it's extremely dangerous people just
look into the case
the cambridge group which was set up in
um
2014 i believe there was even
they wrote about this at the time
exactly there was even u.s state
department cables saying that this lab
is dangerous they're not running the
right safety protocols that there's a
big possibility that there could be a
leak coming from this and then this is
u.s diplomatic cables right there right
in front of our face and then people got
banned
on twitter if you're even talking about
this remember when that paper was
published by the university of south
china in beijing i think it was that
said researchers at the wuhan lab had
been bitten by bats and pedon and that
this caused the virus to leak and then
like two weeks later they're like we're
retracting this paper it's uh oh that
means there's so much of it
happening
the other thing is the woman who ran
that she you know
who um
the bat lady the bat
the
when she heard about the pandemic
she said on the record the first thing i
thought of was this did this come from
our lab
reaction in the leaked emails fauchi
asked i think he asked echo of alliance
is this one of ours yeah and it wasn't
just fouchy
financing and funneling money to this
laboratory it was also the the us
pentagon that was sending money and a
lot of this research is that confirmed
because i remember they requested money
that's actually another piece of
evidence yes that dart in 2018 when eco
health alliance went to darpa and they
specifically if you look at that paper
it's fascinating because the two
distinctive features of the pandemic
virus are the furing cleavage site um
and the way it attaches to the ace2
receptors those are the specific that
make it distinctive and much more
transmissible that's the work that they
asked for money to do in 2018 and darpa
said no we can't give you this money
because it's against the
ban on gain of function the other thing
i just want to say because people make
this point a lot and you mentioned
correctly that there was the ban in
place and then some people say ah but
trump lifted the ban and that's
partly true but the whole story is this
so in 2014 about the obama
administration did put in place a ban on
gain of function research including
uh an advi
the recommendation that exists no new
projects anywhere in the world and a
recommendation that existing projects be
stopped
in 2017 when trump came in they did lift
the ban but they didn't just create a
free-for-all they replaced it with a
different
regulatory
process which said if you are thinking
of doing this kind of research then you
it wasn't a complete band you have to go
through a process including an
assessment by an independent group
outside of nih from
run by hhs and it has to go through this
review process so that so
and both of those
were rules that fauci evaded and that's
i think the interesting thing here we i
i don't think we'll ever prove
right
because the chinese have destroyed so
much evidence and so on what i think we
can prove is that fauci
deliberately evaded the rules that were
in place twice the obama administration
rules and the trump administration rules
and that is i don't know what you want
to call it it's not illegal but it's
professional misconduct or whatever and
so that is where i think we should focus
in terms of because i think you can
absolutely prove that and then they took
the research to china where they were
able to do whatever they wanted however
they wanted as long as they showed the
chinese government what they were doing
the chinese government was looking at it
from the very top they were seeing
everything and it was extremely
dangerous thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00
pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time